.
Stéphanie Blanchet.
- Ce qui est important
pour les gens, pas seulement
pour les puissants.
- Alexa McDonough avait
tout simplement "Alexa".
Elle était, au-delà de
la partisannerie, une femme
se rappelle son ancien
collègue et ancien débuté
fédéral néo-démocrate pourn.
YVON GODIN, ancien député,NPD Ct
- Cette personne-là était
une personne vrae travaillait
fort, comme je vous dis, que
ce soit, pour les démunis,
pour les saisonniers,
pour l'égalité des sans-abris.
Cette personne-là, c'est
une dame, je la considère
comme une grande dame.
- Alex du Nouveau Parti
démocratique de la Nouvelle-
Écosse en 1980.
Un haut fait d'armes
étaient peu nombreuses
à l'Assemblée législative,
au point, par exemple,
où il n'y avait même pas
- En politique, les femmes,
c'était pas faci été été été été
cheffe du parti NPD en Nouvelle-
Écosse pour une dizaine d'années
à Ottawa, c'était la grosse
machine, c'était pas facile
pour elle.
- The election of Alexa
McDonough!
- Alexa McDonough est devenueu i
démocratique du Canada en 1995,
pour être ensuite élue députée
en 1997. Elle a tenu les rênes
Elle est toujours demeurée très
proche des causes de justice
sociale qu'elle a épousées avan.
ACHANCE, dACHANCE, dACHANCE, dA-
Écosse, Halifax Cit.-Sable Isl.e
sociale, donc elle a appri
très bien les défis
des personnes.a McDonough a eu
une grande influ
de nombreuses personnes qui
se sont lancée
comme Lisa Lachance., elle étais
encourageante. Elle m'a
- Le chef du NPD, Jagmeet
écrit qu'elle a consacré sa vie
les femmes en po n'a n'a n'a n'a
jamais reculé devant un défi.ss,
Karl Bélanger, lment
rendu hommage.
- L'unura
constamment dû affronter étaits.
Elle aurait voulu amener
N'empêche, pour bien
des néo-démocrates, elle aura
à la fameuse vague oran
de Jack Layton qui a déferlé
sur le